bienvenue sur diagonale actualité
spécial tournoi de chorus 2009 avec
jean-baptiste moreau jean le baptiste
bonjour stéphane alors je crois que tu
peux nous en parler puisqu'on est à la
fin de ce chorus et que tu reviens en
fait de montpellier où tu as accompagner
alors rien à voir quand on a des noms
mais en journaux alors même s'il y avait
autant devant que dans la dans cette
région de hollande où ça souffle fort
l'a400m dont je reviens de montpellier
il y avait il ya le top-12 donc le top
c'est le nom qu'on donne au championnat
de france féminin par équipe par équipe
dont quand le club voilà le club entre
clubs féminins c'est un match par équipe
de 4 évidemment il n'y a pas autant de
joueuses que l'uni à deux joueurs en top
16 puisque les effectifs sont un peu
moins important pour le moment en france
c'est une compétition qui tente à se
développer
sur la pulsion de
une femme qui travaille activement à la
fédération s'est longtemps manière
bénévole qui s'appelle jocelyne pôle
france jeune et qui a réussi à créer une
pyramide e division et donc elle plus en
plus de clubs qui participent à ce
championnat qui n'est pas encore très
relevé lien il ya quelques bonnes
joueuses mais c'est un bas niveau
amateur on a quand il ya quand même
iraty joue elle-même scriptorial année
quelques stars entre guillemets assure
luu il signait la championne de france
joue pas encore évident à jouer dira
jours avec son avec son club d'evry
probablement il ya des joueuses
étrangères très forte stefano valla par
exemple quand même donc il ya quand même
plein de vie qui me stéphane aura quand
même quand même que quand même été
champion du monde
tu as trouvé d'accord donc il a gagné
c'est beau mais c'est vrai que ça
quelques stars mais après dans une
équipe de 4 il ya trois françaises donc
au niveau français étant ce qu'il est
forcément le niveau des équipes n'est
pas encore très bon entre guillemets
n'est pas homogène en tout cas là mais
je pense que c'est en développement
cette compétition justement que les
clubs les joueuses ont peut-être faire
un effort pour reformer justement tout
s'est joué c'est donc c'est un
championnat intéressant alors la dhr à
montpellier c'était un état organisé par
le club de montpellier échec et sa
présidente anne minier qui a reçu
l'année passée le prix fédéral de
l'innovation féminine pour ceux des ford
envers le secteur féminin et donc
c'était deux poules
dans la 1re division donc nos top 12 est
donc fallait dans les deux premières de
la poule pour se qualifier donc
montpellier et bois-colombes
sont qualifiés dans la première pole et
puis clichy et vandoeuvre dans la
deuxième on retrouve assez fréquemment
au niveau des demi finales d'accord les
finales qui auront lieu en juin et
accompagner l'équipe 1 a accompagné
l'équipe de clichy touché puisque
l'équipe de clichés depuis quelques
années maintenant des deux équipes
voilà de l'équipe de top 16 qui le top
12 de france aussi donc
voilà l'équipe de crise il a fini
première de son groupe devant ben
d'oeuvre années passées on est éliminé
au stade des demi finales par le club de
vendeuvre c'est un très bon club féminin
et puis on s'était classée 3e en battant
pour colons nos voisins le lendemain qui
est aussi un bon club et quelques clubs
comme ça donc on voit que l'effort a été
très bien laver féminine en tout cas
c'est pas très bien fait rire les
féminines c'est je pense qu'il n'y a pas
eu de différence dans la formation des
jeunes entre les garçons et les filles
et que ça se voit pas ce que les jeunes
joueuses de bois colombes par exemple
jouent toujours au club ou un très bon
niveau et se qualifie sans la
professionnelle d'accord donc le jeu
d'échecs en france le jeune et féminin
au reste très bien et ça c'est ça c'est
bien les foxes et des compétitions
nouvelles qui sont là qui s'installe ça
peut casser positif ainsi pas de restant
à mon avis encore de favoriser l'accueil
de ces jeunes femmes dans les clubs mais
sur bon de tout le monde en général mais
des jeunes femmes particulièrement on
connaît un peu mieux des échecs
je pense que quand on aura fait un
effort significatif dans cette
direction-là plus de filles rondes et
chaque voile intégral si donc si vous
êtes si vous êtes une femme je veux que
vous voulez jouer chez vous pouvez il ya
un an maintenant des clubs qui font de
gros efforts envers les féminines en
termes de compétition notamment et
d'accueil donc notamment donc comme
montpellier à paris un cliché aussi donc
n'hésitez pas à colombes à l'échec si
l'équipe a une équipe qui avait une
équipe en top 12 qui malheureusement est
descendue mais on voit que tu aime
beaucoup de filles qui jouent à plaisir
dans ce club
en tout cas la fédération française
s'apprête à créer un label féminin qui
va après une sorte d'inspection donné ce
la fédération m'a donné ce label au club
après qu'on ait jugé 2
qui ont une filière pour que les jeunes
filles à l'appui ce matin aux essais ou
une femme l'accueil qui leur est réservé
voilà donc je pense que durait une
visibilité un peu plus grande
et tout ça pour aller dans les pas
suivre les pas de judit polgar
évidemment et donne harry sebag notre
française qui quand même du temps
rappelle un numéro huit mondial mais
peut-être un peu mieux
sophie millet notre champion de france
qui est derrière et qui suit d'ailleurs
qui viennent d'obtenir le titre de
maître international toute la théorie
mixte et donc qui aura bientôt le team
demi que je pense n'est pas de raison
est là je crois que là sont sous marine
qui est marié grau m les grands maîtres
la mer franco suisse donc elle va y
arriver est pas raison avait dans les
échecs et elle travaille beaucoup
elles y parviennent aujourd'hui un autre
sujet voilà autre sujet aujourd'hui
puisqu'on revient évidemment rue à ce
chorus de lui il n'y a pas de fin de
cette année
bon il ya eu des années où il ya des
femmes notamment il ya eu jeudi de
poignard pour que koné ou s'il a dû
faire le b alors en fait dans le ton
abbayas quand même beaucoup
ja oui fans je peux être yaouvi fans qui
vous cette année voilà la championne du
monde
juniors qui indienne malheureusement son
nom est imprononçable et je me rappelle
plus donc c'est pas du monde junior k
indien qui s'appelle gupta voisins alors
à noter que dans ce pays où il ya des
années a dit ali fille justement il ya
quand même des joueurs comme short que
qui a été finaliste championnat du monde
comme kasparov
donc c'est un tournoi b très relevé et
on voit que les filles ça pousse très
fort notamment willy fans qui est vice
championne du monde 15 ans et voilà qui
va très certainement vraiment pas dans
les pas du dipôle et aaron là je pense
qu'elle va taquiner un peu la hiérarchie
mixte mondial assez vite assez vite
c'est ce que tous les trois grands
maîtres 10 en tout cas donc moi je sais
pas c'est pas c'est pas un avis de fin
donc c'est vraiment un avis d'expert
judith va être accompagnée très bientôt
dans ton alain gilles capri une semi
retraite pour le moment où elle va sans
doute pas désolé un piano de revenir
plus fort wiltord que le corps usb par
exemple on voit qu'elle voit comme ça si
kieran qui est plus de deux mille sept
cents lots saisis dans le port usb
quand on est dernier ce tournoi ah oui
seul dernier ses choix en matière
passionnant c'est chaud ça ne servirait
pas enfants mais ça prouve le niveau
pour le niveau alors on va tout de suite
maintenant passer à ce chorus à 1 le
grand chorus avec une partie qui nous
intéresse plus particulièrement
puisqu'il s'agit de deux grandes
vedettes du circuit mondial actuel ici
en 2009
deux jeunes
grand très grand talent puisque karl
scène m'amuse car sienne qui devient la
coqueluche de décodeurs tv maintenant
puisque je suis beaucoup c'est parti
donc on vous rappelle qu arsène est
encore très jeune de 18 ans 17 ans 18
alors il a 18 ans 18 ans juste numéro 3
ou 4 mondial donc ouais vers la peur la
troîka dont il est aussi d'un terril à
va il a flirté virtuellement avec la
première place - il a eu virtuellement
la peur parce qu'un jour un jour voilà
ça y est ça la salle a mis en joie quand
même et bon évidemment être sur la liste
maintenant numéro un voilà car ce n est
sans doute le meilleur espoir
occidentale de titres de champion de
monde depuis bobby fischer je crois
qu'on peut le dire et voilà c'est un
jeune norvégien de la génération 90
qu'est la génération clairement la plus
forte parmi les adjoints qui joue aux
échecs maintenant dans la partie qu'on a
sélectionné aujourd'hui pour pour les
éditeurs de l'éternel tv c'est la partie
contre gaillac et gitana team qui elle
aussi fait partie de la gamme est qui et
qui est le plus jeune grand mère du
monde de l'histoire de l'histoire c'est
lui qui a eu le titre le plus jeune âge
de 12 ans il ya un mois ouais 12 ans et
quelqu'un l'a donc ukrainien il fait
partie donc de la grande tradition
chrétienne avec les ivantchouk
ponomariov voilà et tout et tout le
toutim et toki team
voilà donc une partie explosive entre
deux jeunes loups aux dents longues
on va voir ça tout de suite magnus
carlsen a les blancs et démarre par le
coût des quatre dans ce conte russe 2009
à sa carrière qui alors
car scène joue quasiment tout le temps
le coût des quatre au premier coup j'ai
remarqué qu'ils jouaient eux quatre de
temps en temps seulement quand il est
entre guillemets sûr que son adversaire
va lui répondre peu simple 4 et 5 c'est
un système qui me plaît avec les blancs
visiblement mais sinon exposit et 4
invariablement d'accord enfin on va
suivre son évolution à carson en cours
je nique encore ont changé alors voilà
c'est 600 n'ont pas fait dans cette
dépense lave qui est maintenant qui m'a
pas fait partie du répertoire de la
plupart des meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
donc ce coup ces six qui visent à
consolider le pion des cinq pour
maintenir le centre kalyev 3006 voilà
que 3 de 3,35 protège ses 4 alors
effectivement l'idée de ce qu'on veut 3
c'est de pouvoir défendre directement le
pion le pion c4 sur un coup comme cali
ces trois au lieu de 3 et bien
effectivement on aurait peut-être pu
prendre le clan c4 en menaçant et c'est
la pointe aussi du coup c'est 6 de
protéger par le goupe b 5 voilà c'est la
soca a laissé 3 si les vins vous eu
quatre l'idée de faire comprendre à ces
cartes derrière des cinq permettrait de
protéger donc que 3 on évite ces gens de
variable est directement en relation le
faux f1 avec le plan ses cadres voilà un
recours aussi typique de ces drames à 6
maintenant tous les plans sur blanc et
on veut on veut pousser b5 avec gan de
temps alors là c'est la position
intéressante dans la théorie moderne le
coup le coup à six au début
avait suscité beaucoup de beaucoup de
critiques de la part de meilleur joueur
du monde lorsqu'il avait été lancée je
pense en tout cas parmi les forces
joueurs par avex echirolles alors le
coup à 6,7 un coup de pied dans
l'ouverture qui est assez criticables au
premier abord
et maintenant j'ai lu un j'ai vu un
commentaire très récemment par un
bourgeois qui disait que je ne comprends
pas qu'on puisse pas jouer à 6 tout le
temps parce que l'idée est très claire
alors qu'elle est l'idée en fait l'idée
c'est de sortir le foot c'est 8
du coup moins en à lang la plupart du
temps essayé de provoquer de créer un
cloud a changé ici
voilà un g4 si on peut pas en iran f5 sa
note composite intérieur 2.5 et un coût
qui j'ai joué à la place d'à 6 mai le
seul petit souci quand on sort le 4
blanche on le connaît tes fans c'est que
la dame peut aller en b3 métro a attaqué
titiller à la fois le pion beceem gct le
buzz 17 et aussi le pion des cinq en
général avec une double menace pénible
puisque les cases blanches son internat
généralement il ya des petits soucis sur
ses deux pions bessette des cinq donc à
l'elysée à 6 me direz vous par rapport à
ce qu'on vient de dire c'est que quand
on joue thème p3 et bien les noirs
peuvent enchaîner tout de suite avec le
groupe des 5 1 les cinq
voilà qui permet non seulement de forcer
les blancs a cédé l'attention puisque
dans d'autres secteurs par exemple sur
la b3 on peut envisager pourquoi pas
bessin quoi peut-être même si on prend
ces quatre avants ou b5
alors on oui mais c'est avec le fou de
cases blanches ortillon pétain alors
rassuré tout cas de l'enfant qui nous
sortirait le fou ici un petit en avant
donc avant wayne pisano chose si on joue
pas à 6 voilà là pour être clair si on
ne joue pas assise là si on joue par
exemple 5 5 alors on joue deux baies
3par helmand voilà qui n'est pas
dramatique et là on peut pas lever 5
pages web et ce pays a prise voilà et
cette coupe d'un métro est un peu
embêtant avec à 6 on peut jouer bessin
voilà donc ces salles ya donc eu 3 alors
que 3 à 6 à 6 il faut savoir que le coup
j'ai peut être également possible on y
va food et roanne en fout des trois
maintenant sur le fou du coup j'ai cadre
on expliquer l'idée donc m'étonne on n'a
plus peur elle donne des trois parce que
b5
il n'y a pas de problème sur 17 on gagne
du temps même
quand on s'écarte voilà qu'avec les bd
deux protections de calais b c et francs
pour mon visage de reprendre du
cavallino à leurs hommes en réalité on
peut
on va pouvoir se développer en bougeant
la dame en c2 ou en b3 et de danse en
tolérer la femme dispose d'une structure
de pions si on est obligé de reprendre
du plongeon on peut alors même si c'est
possible dans ce type de structure un
peu fermé comme ça le fait d'avoir le
roi au centre et des pions doublé n'est
pas très grave
le jeu n'est pas ouvert non monsieur roy
mesure ce cadre facilement en échange de
l'affaiblissement de la structure de
pions les blanquetiers une belle grunge
et et surtout la perte de fou voilà donc
c'est une possibilité mais c'est un
business date choisie cavaliers voilà
tranquillement cavale et b17 on
développe du coup les noirs alors eu
l'idée aussi est à ces manifs c'est que
sur dame c2 qui a été semé par 15 scènes
ici même ces deux larrons jour de 6
simplement et on ne craint pas cavalier
e 5 qui prendrait de l'espace au centre
et qui attaquerait le fou j'ai quatre en
tout cas qu'ils laissent traîner changer
pour l'échangé avec les loyers 17
contrôle donc pour l'instant tous les
coups sont assez logique
donc petit rock là par les blancs les
noirs en profitent maintenant dépenser 4
1 une fois que le fou à bouger
évidemment le fait de prendre 104 ça
oblige à rejouer ce qu'on veut pas
prendre du cavalier évidemment parce que
si on prenait en qu'avec le cavalier en
c4 on se ferait casser l'europe fou
prend cabaye f3 et j'ai profiteront avec
la un roi un peu affaibli donc on
reprend ici du fou en ckd donc on a joué
le fou deux fois puisqu'on a joué
d'abord en d3 plus à penser qu'a donc en
général et noir très souvent dans ce
type puissions attendre que fouet jouer
avant de prendre dans ses 4 alors qui
précise on ne peut pas être terrorisé
non plus part parce entre guillemets
perte de temps
je sais que dans un de mes cours clichy
j'ai un élève qui me posent à peu près
de systématiquement la même question
mais c'est incroyable sur des princes et
4 faut penser à cannes finalement on
perd un temps oui non et donc on se rend
pas bien on ne perd pas de temps parce
que en fait dépenser 4 france et 4 et
nous avons joué un coup les blancs
voient un coup comment dire que l'un des
deux camps a perdu un temps maintenant
simplement les noirs ont souhaité
modifier la position
ils ont fêté procès captel pour quelle
france et 4 et voilà c'est un choix
qu'ils ont fait
fawcett est là pour les blancs c'est
l'heure de passer à l'offensive au
centre avec le caue 4 voilà donc ça
c'est ça ses responsables là car scène
je vous garde donc là il peut envisager
soit joué le simple pourquoi pas avec
une petite phalange de pions en
direction du roi oui une case cas pour
le cavalier voir pour la dame pourquoi
pas avec ou avoir même poussé des 5
voilà des symptômes assez rarement parce
que le bureau de qui rend défunt serait
très bien bien sûr prestance et bien
protégée y aller un gain de 4,6 alors en
fait on se fait quelquefois quelques
quelques émissions qu'on fait avec des
parties de magnus carsen et
on commence à savoir à peu près comment
il joue maintenant en fait il a une
culture classique les immenses camps
scène et il a un jeu positionnelle c'est
pas qu'il fait penser à dans la pureté
au jeu de binic par exemple avec un très
très grand respect du centre et ils
jouent souvent pour avoir cette phalange
de pions des 4 4 et c'est très souvent
qui les touche qui ne touche pas tout de
suite
oui ils consolident d'abord pour 60 où
ils s'envoient là il va là je sais pas
grand suspense cette session qui va
replacer ses pièces comme il le souhaite
sauf si l'autre c'est une opportunité
intéressante éventuellement mais là il
serait typiquement du genre hvb 3 fourbe
et 2 h 3 tours d un tour au 1 m quelques
tours au centre v2 voilà airs ensuite
entre eux et ensuite poussé au sein
pouces au dessin l'envoi en fonction de
ce qui s'est passé
maintenant petit rock replacements déjà
du foot car scène tout de suite food et
3 voilà alors la menace ils menacent
tout de suite puisque la menace très au
cinq attaques lecavalier et six
cavaliers bouche par exemple en d5 hop
vous prend elle cet échec au roi et
ensuite je ramène le fou tranquillement
j'ai gagné un gros pions donc les noirs
ça justifie le coup suivant des normes
h6 voit la petite fenêtre
ici on évite le fourrage 7 en plus
assister plaisir à jouer puisque on
empêche le couffo g5 ultérieure donc
c'est toujours un coucou voilà la
désagréable impression aussi c'est que
ça fait une petite cible éventuellement
pour le pousser un on a un grand besoin
de l'attak mais encore une fois c'est un
coup qu'on peut pas jouer gratuitement
pour chaque fois il faut bien sûr il
faut vraiment être motivé pour le jouer
parce que ce coup et affaiblissant alors
il l'est moins que le coût g6 évidemment
le coup j'ai six affaiblir et toutes les
cases mois alors que là on a fait bien
peu le gaz mais il reste le pion à vii
et le pion aux 6 donc ça tient encore
les cases blanches en partie h3 a posé
la question aux fous échange du faux
contre car il serait sans doute pas une
bonne idée que ce jeu
les blancs peuvent ouvrir la position
par des cinq quand ils veulent je n'ai
pas fermé on mettre le four b2 avec une
très belle batterie est sans doute une
attaque forte à outrance permettre de
donner la peur de plus si tôt alors
qu'on ne connaît pas de purs fois je
sais hélas car scène prend une décision
responsable en ce moment là puisqu'il
joue le coup eux 5
donc si responsable pourquoi parce que
bon il bien sûr il est bien ce qu on est
content d'avoir une saine puisque on va
chasser le câble et 6
on a un pion qui est un avant poste
important pour une attaque contre le roi
une petite falloir regarder la phalange
de pions ici qui loue qui lorgnait qui
les rendaient vers la droite ici le
désavantage évidemment c'est que c'est
le pion des quatre quarts jelen parce
que du coup il n'y a pas de pions pour
protéger des quatre on voit qu'il pourra
jamais jouer en d5 ceux qui ont au moins
un sacrifice dont on voit mal utilité
puisque là il serait très très vite bien
verrouillé par l'action c6 des 5 et donc
ceux qui ont des quatre peut être
l'objet d'une cible à moyen ou long
terme sur la colonne des suppléments
poste des pièces cours d'ici pour faire
pression sachant que pour l'instant
c'est bien protégé par karine f3 le
phocéen peut venir en mai de surprotéger
voran 3 donc il n'y a pas de danger
immédiat mais c'est quand même peu en
arrière et al'avantage par contre du qm5
qui lui est un avant poste
alors là on sait pas c'est que personne
n'a pas fait mentir puisqu'il a pris une
décision assez donc de quoi de quoi il a
eu peur par rapport à 62,11 je pense
enfin quasi sûr qu'il avait peur que
notre ami t'a dit qu'il me joue c5 c6 c5
et k62 pions avant même qu'il ait eu le
temps de centrer sur ces 5 avec le
cavalier 17 et le fou c'est celle qui
protège les blancs peuvent pas jouer des
cinq donc ça pète le pion des quatre ça
le fait exploser et donc le centre des
blancs n'existent plus donc ils jouent
aux 5 pour
prendre une décision tout de suite car
elle était simple et là on voit
maintenant l'idée katché de cartes scène
quand il a joué h3 il joue maintenant
gicquel g4 et voilà c'est là on comprend
l'idée de demander car c'est tout de
suite si les noir jaune rouge et 6 il ya
une batterie ici on prend tout
simplement gagnon il faut prendre puis
on prend dimpre en gagnant puisque les
rats qui fait de ce n'est pas acceptable
heureusement car y'a qui n'a vu tout ça
et il joue l'intermédiaire très
important le coût intermédiaire toujours
en cavale et b4 j'attaque la dame et le
fou est donc
cette petite manip ne fonctionne pas
tout de suite en juin contre tamedia ont
pas attention à ce que notre adversaire
ne ne part pas lointain mais l'ironie
des trois en attaquant une nouvelle
chose voilà c'est assez clair qu'on
risque pas grand chose de crédible et 4
mais on n'a pas mis le descendeur il est
protégé par le feu c'est donc il n'y
aura pas de malheur donc on peut se
parler de se croire médias mais on vous
invite quand même vérifier quand même
assez bien qu'entre juin quotas meilleur
n'est sûr parce qu'il peut se faire
contrer lui-même par notre intermédiaire
c'est ce que fait d'ailleurs car c'est
un petit coup intermédiaire au sort là
il est quasiment obligé parce que s'ils
perdaient le fou de cases blanches à ce
moment là qu'a dit qu'il n'aurait aucun
souci a bien sûr vous pourrez remettre
le x 5 rangées 6 après avoir pris le fou
et donc je pousserai énorme mince à
santiago del blanches je n'aurais pas
d'opposants le fout des blancs a disparu
mission donc fois cet échec roche mythe
et a maintenant tranquillement dans b 1
oui voilà et le problème sur le fond
chaîne continue à se poser alors si les
noirs vous foulez si c'est toujours le
même problème la victoire voilà alors
c'est là qu'il fallait bien calculer et
les noirs ont prévu en fait un peu trop
le choix voilà il ya un contrecoup c'est
le coût qui est très intéressant
d'ailleurs c'est pas mal c'est le coût
est de 5
voilà f5 alors l'idée simple c'est que
je coupe tout de suite la liaison entre
le dernier fou donc si je prends le
fourrage saint gobain je perds le fois
je sais tu reprends tout simplement oui
et si les blancs prennent du plomb est
bon il ya on perd fourchette et puis
enfin on ne perd pas vraiment puisqu'on
peut jouer oui mais en fait les blancs
ont regagné la pièce oui mais après il
ya une sacrée pression sur le petit rock
devant donc
on peut pas trop se permettre imaginons
par exemple que plus on prend avec 5,6
puis on prend un essai mais déjà on
n'attaque plus on n'attaque plus le x 7
oui on a donc là on prend on prend la
pose en voilà et la même sur une
découverte même sur m6 qui fait
découvert pourquoi pas square dit la
dame bien fait échec mais là on peut
ramener le ferons nous quand j'ai six
mais bon les blancs peuvent toujours
prendre le pion puisque mon attaque la
dague
alors maintenant après il faut parler il
faut parler de la stratégie c'est à dire
que d'en prendre un bain et le fouet en
fait c'est même pas de stratégie point
de vue on ferme et on est obligé de
jouer cavalier ou quatre il faut jouer
qu'à lyon 4 saint saulve compères la
baraque après 9,3 et le trouble voilà et
à la fin le cas les froids et perdu donc
voyez donc ça marche pas tout ça est pas
bon
donc il faut absolument faire 5 très
bons coups de défense très beaucoup
défense on peut pas se permettre de
faire j'ai pris un excellent c'est pas
bon donc il reste le seul autre coup
voilà le coût entre guillemets
positionnelle alors un autre coup est
envisageable mais qui est pas bon c'est
de prendre 25 dans ce cas là les noirs
reprendrai le fou et en a perdu et les
ancrer un affaiblissement ses pions en
tout cas ils vont profiter de leur
histoire que les blancs sont créé
eux-mêmes un décès mort parce que les
enjeux d'un v8 tout simplement et le
plus ancien qui est perdu est le roi
regarder avec ses pions complètement
d'hérens n'oublie pas non plus que quand
les blancs jouent eux 4,5 pour jouer la
taxe sur le petit rock ils affaiblissent
grave dans laquelle des 5 voilà donc le
cavalier b4 pourra ensuite gagné la
casse d 1 ha oui c'est parce tactique et
quand même puissante
il faut faire attention donc le seul
autre coup financer la prise en passant
la fameuse donc alors les blanc et noir
jouent le coup le pion de gaz on vous
rappelle le principe de la prise en
passant les blancs ont le droit
uniquement dans ce cas là quand le un
pion vient de jouer de deux cas juste le
coup d'après uniquement on a le droit de
prendre en m6 comme si le plan est bougé
d'une seule case on a droit de prendre
avec un pion pas avec une pièce on voit
rappel pour les y est pour ceux qui
marquent loin si c'est pas très clair
pour sacrée leçon de louis van gaal et
le sont effectivement effectivement les
leçons
pour les débutants en échec que donald
tv leçon sur internet dans le catalogue
dargaud noté ou trouverez la leçon qui
vous explique
eh bien comment les pions bouge et
notamment comment on peut prendre en
passant ça ne fait qu'un peu un peu
anciennes
bizarre ouais mais qui existe un qui
font partie du jeu et qui règle la
nageuse c'est plutôt une règle qu'à
moderniser le jeu oui parce qu'avant en
fait on pouvait pas bouger le nombre de
cases c'est parce qu'on a inventé le
fait d'avoir accéléré qu'on s'est dit
oui mais attention parce qu'avant on
pouvait prendre le pion maintenant on
peut plus alors voilà donc on a inventé
cette règle intermédiaires qui en fait
une modernisation du voeu qui arrive est
relativement tard mais toujours en
passant une sorte de péage signe ph
saint pée donc un péage
non mais je crois que c'était celta
comparatif donc on y voit là tu en
prends f6 pour les blancs et hop tout de
suite regardé grâce à ce coup donc cette
prise en passant médiéval un coup de
péage au médiéval on vienne de
reprotéger directement le faux hachette
qui a pas de problème direct alors ouais
c'est une passe d'armes quand une
tactique pas simple est ce qu'on voit là
les noirs peuvent jouer regardez là
encore un coup qui crée une contre
menace là aussi les cours sur les
contres menace d'ailleurs qu'on a fait
avec sur l'assaut simplement pour
expliquer ce que c'est qu'une menace et
une contrebasse alors cavaliers pros m6
et regardez donc le fourrage 5 est
toujours attaquée par un pion mais mais
mais on continue d'attaquer une pièce
mon sort puisque le cavalier à six
attaques le foll 7 et donc la dame
pourra pas évidemment reprendre le
cavalier puisque le roi veille alors
maintenant car ça mais un tournant c'est
à dire que son
mon petit piège tactique n'a pas n'a pas
marché entre guillemets parce
qu'évidemment il avait tout prévu pour
l'après voit tout mais sur ces gens là
ne font que très peu de fautes de calcul
c'est juste une question d'évaluation de
la position à la fin de la phase
tactique c'est ça qui est important
bien sûr ce niveau là c'est l'accès à ce
jour ils voient tous les deux la même
chose mais ils jugent pas de la même
façon de leur plan après ouais voilà
donc la circulent sont fous bon ça va
pas marcher très bien parce que le fou à
chaque voilure aussi rentrer à la maison
et finalement chacun aura des cases
faible way en attendant semaine a
préféré un peu les noirs qui ont une
colonne f qui est intéressante
bien sûr on connaisse voilà avec
cavaliers des cinq cavaliers f4 et là ça
chauffe
donc en fait car cela est prévu un truc
où il finit par prendre le fou h1 il
prend quand même le fourrage singles et
noir sont obligés de reprendre la pièce
perdue donc terry pratchett et là l'idée
alors parce que les sciences des fous de
cases blanches dans ces conditions-là
l'intéressent parce que le petit pion
aux champs libres et vous qui va aider
les blancs à contrôler la cage des six
équipes de geci ce qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait mettre
voilà la fourchette d'un carlos et en
garder regardez donc le coup c'est tout
s'explique
il veut venir d'arsène ici pour venir
faire une belle fourchette 3 pièces 6 6
les studios trois pièces et là c'est une
belle fourchette 3 pièces alors cavalier
e 5 menace tout simplement cabaye échec
et fourchettes notamment pour prendre la
qualité et pourquoi pas aussi prendre le
fou est en tout cas faire un échec
pénible avec un cavalier pénible aussi
puisqu'il a angers 6
pas facile d'aller d'aller prendre le
virage 5 en plus qui protège ce cavalier
on peut même envisager de le laisser là
un certain temps donc c'est toujours
agréable
là il faut jeter un petit coup à la
position c'est vrai qu'il ya cette belle
cage des six il ya aussi la colonne g
qui est intéressante pour attaquer bien
sûr parce qu'en fait on a ouvert cette
colonne
le roi pourrait venir à lens on case
blanche ici pourquoi pas parce qu'il
n'ya pas le fou de foot cases noires de
fou noir de cases blanches
on pourrait protéger un échec de la ne
serait pas vraiment embêtant pour jouer
2 3 par exemple et on pourra envisager
de mettre des tours après sur cette
colonne pour attaquer le voilà il ya
beaucoup de pièces qui peuvent attaquer
le petit rock on va le pousser un qui
d'ordinaire si inquiet si ce qui attend
que le cavalier les alliés qui va très
bien bougé aussi sur la case de 4 voilà
il faut que tout le monde s'organise
dans l'ordre pour que tout le monde
passe à peu la stratégie donc on va voir
comment car cette position là alors 3g 8
approche est très proche de lui alors il
fait passer la dame d'abord en gagnant
un tempo ça c'est important dans le jeu
pour l'attack cette fois-ci de griller
tempo alors si on peut le dire puisque
on attaque le pion aux six avec les
chefs alors on attaque voilà on gagne du
tempo puisqu'en fait on menace dans 36
effectivement un petit chèque donc il
faut que les noirs pas cette menace à
laurianne coup simple qui est jouée par
le goff peu par cardiokine ben non c'est
torres 6 alors l'idée des noirs en jour
ce genre de coups c'est très
certainement de ramener le cash est sûre
et suite ou en général il protège très
bien droit en bolide est séparé des
menaces aussi mais c'est vrai qu'ils
utilisaient des cavaliers il recueillera
m le cavalier en ifsi c'est évident mais
ça aurait posé il préfère voir ça
libéré à caser fuite sans doute pour son
cavalier sans doute c'est vrai que c'est
rassurant en général quand un cavalier
ici c'est très difficile à tapis le roi
protège très bien je propose
il faut pousser la dame évidemment j 6
parce qu'elle étouffe
elle est tout frais
loin loin d'alger 4 alors à noter qu'en
gardant la dame en vis-à-vis avec le roi
on pourra envisager plus tard des fous
prend 1,6 le pion au projet ont doublé
sur la colonne des menaces à un acte en
date aussi qu'on protège le pire des
quatre et on a un petit oeil en même
temps ici sur le pion des quatre qui est
menacée par la dame aura donc beaucoup à
la fois à l'heure parce que ça me prend
aussi c'était plus forte que bien sûr
nous donc cavalli g5 de la part des
noirs donc c'est pas une fuite c'est
angers saint qui vient au g5 cavaliers
c4 alors maintenant je croise il ya un
autre trajet pour son cavalier
alors il met le terrier ici en c4 alors
parce que lecavalier jestin grands
peuvent venir e4 aussi on aurait changé
il veut pas échanger lecavalier il veut
il préfère jouer car les laissait carte
qui coûte
l'idée c'est qu'à fait partie de ces
coûts marrante cavaliers où on croit que
perry se dirige vers la finale dames
c'est possible mais il est aussi un oeil
sur des droits parce qu'il peut revenir
à son tour la case de cinq mois que
lecavalier le sac les parties en soute a
bel et bien là on met le deuxième on a
de grosses pièces qui marche du cavalier
qui mettent des nuages sur le roi noir
trajet étonnant des bois les noirs
ramène même leur propre cavaliers en d5
ici voilà donc ça c'est un cavalier qui
revient peu ans d'efforts il a plus rien
à faire en d4 en d4 ne faisait rien il
va peut-être pu tenter un peut-être en
cavale et ces deux cas les c2 avec
l'idée évidemment fourchette tour epyon
c'était c'était c'était envisageable
mais en fait le problème c'est sans
doute que les blancs auraient pris
angers 5 attaquants même la tour et
ensuite jouer un simple tour d un voilà
actuellement avec ce qu intervienne
voilà c'était pas une vraie menace donc
ils préfèrent jouer cavalier des cinq
donc ici continue l'ata qui veulent
chasser il chasse le cavalier volaille
choisi de ne pas pris peau est envisagé
de prendre aussi bien sûr puis envisager
de prendre donc les 5 ans était un coût
tout à fait possible sur hp g5 un peu
trop dangereux de prendre de prendre le
pion quand même alors prends le pion ca
fait peur parce qu'évidemment la tour
peut bouger par exemple en f2 et l'afld
le foot à kadam ça fait un peu peur mais
ça aurait cassé peut-être la structure
c'était possible mais il choisir notre
cour qui est aussi intéressant actifs h4
pour dévier ce cavalier et remettre la
dame en vis-à-vis du roi du roi noir car
les recettes de la part des noirs qui
est à peu près le second n'est pas notre
coup faudra parvenir à cette île au
rythme là c'est pas mal de 17 pour
rester pièce ça comprenez un manque d
espace on sait bien qu'il faut changer
c'est là que les liens sont contents
d'avoir une deuxième quart et là parce
qu'ils se disent je peux toujours
échangé remettre un cavalier voire même
s'il échange lui mettre le nom dans des
coups de tête grand maître c'est que ça
va commencer par ceux de l'harmonie
après général pour un oui c'est ce qui
va se passer
ouache 1 donc ça c'est l'idée que tu
signaler la colonne g parce que l'idée
des blancs si simplement de faire tour
g1 est ici on a ce qu'on appelle une
batterie et la menace ce serait d'un
projet sept matches et on commence à
créer des menaces pas facile apparaît
pour pour les noirs donc les noirs
anticipons fait cette menace a bétonné
au mas a bétonné fouet suite voilà donc
je veux surprotège à cannes g7 alors à
noter que ces deux tours est très
importante puisqu'elle garde l'oeil sur
1,6 le cavalier c'est aussi parce qu'il
ya le fond qu attend que ça se sacrifie
sur 1,6 ou prend 1,6 c'est plus
défenseur le plus je sais tu ne protège
en rien puisque la dame est en vis-à-vis
du roi faut trois noms
oui formater les enjeux donc il sort le
faux droit steeve afin de libérer la
tour 1 c'est aussi ça l'idée est là qu
il propose un coup de réorganisation
c'est à dire que le cas validé cinq est
bon il est bien il est sur une case for
qui est décoratif venir peuvent être
mieux voilà mais il faut qu'ils viennent
et les autres pièces à la défense ou à
l'échangé des pièces blanches donc il
joue avait lieu cette cale cette voie là
donc ça c'est intéressant cavaliers
hausse est effectivement il veut venir y
5 voit l'avenir avec encore
malheureusement parce que là il
protègera g 7 h 6 et en plus ce cas bien
moins cinq ehpad et logeable
malheureusement pour kg quineleu prendre
deux cavaliers au set c'est que
temporairement ce cavalier créé un
embouteillage dans le camp noir et
notamment couple l'action d'amd vite sur
la tour f 6 et 15 cents
l'architecte brio de ce court moment où
les pièces -2 sont harmonieusement passé
ouais ça c'est c'est sans doute un coup
imprécise ce coup en cavale et
cavalières 7 c'est une faute voilà sans
doute ici les les noirs auraient pu
jouer à avoir bien tenu ici un historien
ils ont ils ont bien résisté à l'attaqué
des blancs et donc la position n'était
pas plus mauvaise pour les noirs et les
blancs mais sur fallait jouer sans doute
quelque chose comme condamne ces 7es et
ramener ensuite là pour à 8 par exemple
en 8 bien protégé pions et 6 et et
ensuite peut-être faire cette manoeuvre
mais c'est une vérité aussi jeu d'échecs
qu'il faut qu'il faut savoir qu'il faut
retenir c'est que même dans une position
équilibrée
c'est difficile de jouer la position
retourner à une position de défense
son patron la position d' attaque on a
un enfant se sent même ne serait-ce que
psychologiquement beaucoup plus libre de
trouver les cours avec les noirs on a
l'impression qu'on doit surtout pas se
tromper et c'est dur coup aux échecs
malheureusement quand on se force à
faire encore plus attention aux aspects
cosseron c'est vrai donc la position de
défense et pour les 95% des joueurs plus
dur avec une position d'intel c'est vrai
qu'en général quand yens on dit souvent
quand une première erreur c'est
s'enchaînent les suivantes
là ça va être
mieux maintenant des canadiens ce 15e
trouve un très joli coup très jolie pour
profiter de la désorganisation des
pièces noires et joue cavalier bessy
saur ça c'est super alors regardez
calais b 6 alors ça paraît très bizarre
j'attaque la torah 8 c'est ça l'idée
si les noirs viennent en tourbe et 8
regardez le deuxième cavaliers peuvent
venir en 17 attaques la tombée de cas
plus de cases tout les cas sont pris par
les cavaliers ce extraordinaire quand
même de piau j'ai pigé une tour avec les
cavaliers et alors
l'autre problème c'est que si les noirs
ben oui on peut dire ma tension mais le
canal est un prix certes le carlit
emprise mais si les noirs prennent les
contrairement aux apparences c'est pas à
cause de l'attaqué à la découverte du
fou et 3 soit d'un v6 est inoffensif
puisque on va jamais récupérer une pièce
avec un déçu c'est pas ça voilà c'est un
autre thème tactique c'est la fourchette
c'est cette fourchette là et ça gagne
plus que la qualité puisque la dame ne
peut pas elle doit bouger elle peut pas
protéger la tour f 6 et on va prendre la
touriste avec échecs et les noirs ne
peuvent pas reprendre en 6 pi qu'il y
aurait toujours cet échec de la dame
ça reste quand même qu'à un gain de
qualité puisque dans une pièce pour
vendre une tour c'est quand même quelque
chose des positions sans doute alors
donc donc il reste le seul coup un temps
déduction il mais triste effectivement
qu'il fait peine à voir
c'est le coup tour à tour à sept alors
faut rapidement la torre et sommes en
tout cas temporairement lé pavillon 8
donc on peut pas l'attaquer deuxième
carrier s'est passé mais dans le côté on
a peur parce que on a comme le fou 3 qui
ont vis-à-vis de la tour oui c'est une
pièce qui n'est pas lié aux autres
pièces donc il ya toujours un problème
avec souplesse envers couper couper du
jeu voilà d'ailleurs les et blanc pour
se dire je pourrais jouer maintenant
peut-être cavaliers 17 attaques la tour
et 6 défaites tu vas être servis
stéphane mais c'est pas le cavalier p6
qui est important ce qu'elle épaississe
parce que il appelle option b de bouger
donc la tourasse est de regagner le
droit à un petit ça marche pas parce
qu'il ya car les pointes cavaliers en
fait intermédiaire
et il faut reprendre du cavalier sinon
ça nous libère donc allé prendre
cavaliers on est obligé de reprendre du
cavalier et il ya plus de problèmes et
la torah c'est de voir venir au chômage
ou élevé 5 et sei la tour 7 pourra
revenir au jeu
donc voilà plutôt cavalier e 17 e mail
autres cavaliers on attaque toujours à
tour f 6 et puis alors effectivement
comme tu les signaler cette tour à cette
allée hors jeu c'est comme s'ils
n'existaient pas ces deux cavaliers non
seulement sur un poison dans le camp
noir mais en plus il mobilise une pièce
entière et pas n'importe laquelle une
grosse tour voilà ces cavaliers sont
très forts moindre qu'en noir les
paralyse complètement les pièces et donc
ce sont deux pièces dont il ne faut pas
se séparer et la menace évidemment
cavaliers prendre pour échec alors
heureusement le cavalier vii à un oeil
sur a6 qui fait qu'on n'aura pas peur de
foot champions à cause grâce aux sept
cavaliers donc on peut encore jouer tour
f5 mais déjà on voit que les noirs sont
très resserrée et déjà les années blanc
en gros avantage du fait de cette tour
qui est totalement mobilisée donc le but
maintenant des blancs c'est de mobiliser
sans doute l'atout récents voire même
aimait bien sûr la tour 1 et je vous
virtuellement avec une grosse pièce de
plus pour attaquer les noirs ce qui est
un gros souci c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin
de prendre toute la pièce pour jouer
avec une tour de plus si on a réussi à
isoler une pièce adverse
on peut considérer qu'on joue avec une
pièce de plus au classement voilà qui
joue pas c'est comme une pièce prise
donc voilà c'est comme qu'esprit à
l'étouffée on irait au go qu'elle est
morte
oui bonjour j'ai un bon normal car c'est
en tout cas il m'a ses pièces il veut
sans doute joué peut-être aussi
peut-être des tours j'ai deux suivis de
tours agéens ça va faire beaucoup de
pièces si on pourra envisager des
sacrifices a donc il faut faire très
attention
donc là un kayak voile à calais des 5
alors l'idée très simple bon maintenant
ça va ça suffit avec des cavaliers quel
dessein je menace d'échangés ce cas les
décisions a pas trop de solutions dont
car ce n est obligé de les changer
ouais alors là il aurait peut-être pu
essayer
dernis à bali où cavaliers prend la
fuite alors là il aurait pu tenter
cavale et prend fou menace mat
donc si vous prenez du roi vous prenez
dans la tranche des scènes avec échec
il faut donc prendre de la dame alors si
on prend de ladom il ya tout un souci
c'est que le cavaliere revient encore en
jeu par 17 attaques la dame et la dame
ne peut pas bouger sinon ses notes
sinon c'est matt donc il a raté ça oui
mais là c'est un fait c'est plus
compliqué que ça parce que ce clavier
prend la fuite
c'est un honneur de jouer on va revenir
en deuxième groupe blanc voilà qu'elle
les prend la fuite
là il faut que lee il faut que les noirs
accepte en fait de faire grimper en
voilà et se sauve moi se sauve parce
qu'ils vont avoir du contrôle jeu
ensuite sur des projets cet îlot perdu
contre ogeu peut-être plus tard sur le
pion h4 avec la dame et le cavalier b6
est toujours en l'air escale et en l'air
voilà donc on peut envisager ça c'est
une position très compliqué où le roi
noir est complètement extrait de son
petit rôle initial mais en tout cas
c'est une manière de défendre qui n'est
pas inintéressante pour les noirs alors
il y avait il ya une autre solution
aussi sur sept sur sept variantes donc
cavalier prend calais.fr oui donc d'un
prend ensuite quand même et sur calais
17 qui fort puisqu'elle ne peut pas
jouer on peut jouer quand l
intermédiaire cavaliers 6 mais attention
et attaque la dame et propose les
changes des cavaliers attention parce
que les deux dames sont en l'air et de
200 m donc vous avez le trait vous avez
attaqué la dame si vous attaquez la
vôtre ces deux choses moi les soit on
prend la tête de l'autre soit on regarde
où le thème peut bouger bien sûr sachant
que la dame sera toujours en crues voilà
parce que s'y passe comme si la dame
s'en va et c'est un échec par exemple ça
veut dire qu'on gagne la dame bien sûr
dame s'en va a fait échec le roi bouge
on prend la dame de trois là dans ce cas
là on peut en profiter pour prendre du
matériel voilà un matériel plus gros que
ce qu'on risque de perdre là on risque
de perdre quoi un cavalier en cas d'
échange de dames si on fait cavaler
prendre car les programmes pour prendre
cavaliers trois points car lyon n'a rien
gagné mais si on fait dans prend tout
c'est pas qu'on ne donnant pas la dame
puisque l'autre dame est toujours
attaquer les noirs évidemment doivent
reprendre ou cibula dames il suffira de
bouger la nôtre voire même de prendre 26
donc il faut absolument prendre est là
et bien il suffit de faire cavalier
prend dames et après on apprend fait le
bilan on regarde et bien vous avez bien
une qualité de plus une tour contre un
des cavaliers même sans doute jouer des
seuils alors non mais c'est presque même
essentiel dans notre position nous
voyons dans les pages couleurs les
cavaliers très très fort dans la
position malgré la qualité de plus bien
sûr à dessein le four reprend reprend
espoir et oui parce qu'on attaque la
torah 7 on va pouvoir échanger un pion
et les tours vont pouvoir jouer à fond
et valoriser la 2 sombre dont les pièces
à longue portée commence à prendre de la
valeur
bien sûr beaucoup plus de valeur que les
pièces à courte portée donc voilà une
combine quand même raté cinq ans il a
raté sa note tout à fait arrêter ça donc
vous voyez que même les grands maîtres
peuvent rater ça donc il a fait cavaler
prend cabinet au lieu de cavalli grand
fou qui était une combinaison sans doute
déjà gagnante tout reprend cavaliers de
karuïa kinky panique pas il prend le bon
cavalier prend pas il prend celui ci en
tout cas donc tranquillement et
qu'arsène choisit maintenant de jouer
qu'à laisser cinq n'ont qu'à les profits
de parler avec pascal et ses scènes qui
attaquer le système les points de fuite
aussi le pion aussi c'est permis voilà
magnus carlsen pense que pour ce que son
attaque sur la colonne g et suffisantes
donc qui fait qu'il prend et cuites pour
supprimer le défenseur du pion des
planches 17 et en dessert avant
voilà mais c'est d'en prendre fou et il
a vu tout simplement
il est pro même pas aussi s'en fait mais
vous tour touché trois répondent pas aux
six mois les prix aussi ça c'est
possible ça nous car à qui nourrit
réactivé sa tournée tokyo 13 à 8
hélas m en 1 8 de plus si c'est vrai que
vital en 6e position symptômes plus mais
c'est d'un côté céder pioncer des pions
qui sont doublés certains y voient plus
important d'avoir la seule à ne pas
inviter sur lui donc autres plantes
carsen tout simplement tour j'ai trois
et on veut simplement masse et les tours
mais évidemment c'est pas pareil que la
combine commune voir qui était quand
même beaucoup plus puissante est assez
simple bizarrement qui avait là
relativement si c'est un plaisir simple
pour un joueur de niveau ii car c'est
bien sûr nation donc tour j'ai trois
tours a eu donc très très important
quand on sait pas quand on n'a pas de
coût évidemment toujours replacer ces
pièces en l'occurrence ou de façon aussi
mal placé que c'est criant voilà et ne
pas hésiter life et wade pourquoi il
aurait pu activer en jambes et 5000 aura
affaiblissant pioncer 6 pour rien donc
là il quand on regarde une structure
propre très solide et 3,8 et il veut
simplement des venir au centre venir la
rescousse un peu de son roi donc tour à
g1 et là on peut plus trop défendre le
le pion g7
il ya trois pièces à l'attack il ya qu
une seule pièce en défense avec le roi
et on peut pas simplement il récupère le
piège est saine mais il va avoir deux
pions ici quand même doublé donc les
noirs ont sans doute en récupérer les
dons croix à suite
et là d'un problème si ça y est y prend
1,6 maintenant même temps qu'il a doublé
les tout en fait on parle de 7 mais bien
aussi parce qu'il se dit que g7 il peut
le prendre après cette île veut
sacrifier pourquoi pas de tour contre la
dame possible
ce soit se sont intéressés à des
logiciels concret après sur les cases
noires par exemple mention même il ya
aussi ces check points glanés sur donc
tout reprend h5 de la part des noirs on
récupère déjà un pion et ont fait
pression structurelle 4 ce qui serait
intéressant pour nous parce que ses
autres proches 4 si les noirs et les
blancs sont obligés de jouer trois jets
d'eau ils coupent eux aussi leur tour
qu'ils sont doublés un danger car de
carson vient protéger c'est 4 et réitère
aussi la mince échanger 7 et la lay line
effet de stabiliser cette position avec
g 6 4 6 2 parce que c'est parce que
c'est la reprise mais c'est vrai que sur
d'apprendre et s'ils sont prêts pour
prend aux quatre et ont été solides
arriverez les pièces qu en forêt tout
reproche quatre échecs et 3g 2 serait
forcé les plans sont mieux 1 voilà bien
sûr c'est évident mais c'était l'idée de
khanaqine de laisser passer l'orage on
est en france en leur rappelant à se
mettre entre les tours blanches donc g6
et là alors qu'arsène joué un très bon
coup dans cette position ça sera sans
doute très intéressant des cinq ans la
d5 alors l'idée de d5 c'est pas
tellement que ceux qui ont fait des
menaces c'est que ça libère le fou que 3
1 qui peut venir en éclats de faire un
bon échec mortel sur le roi suroît g7
d'un projet si ce matin alors il s'avère
que s'avère finalement
ce coup même s'il avait l'air très bon
n'est pas le meilleur que peut-être d'un
projet
quand même meilleur d'un projet ci soit
la version
pragmatique du matériel était quand même
un peu plus sympa mais dans l'absolu le
coup de coude et 5 et un coup à retenir
bien sûr et c'est un sacrifice de
dégagement on appelle ça des quatre
dessins pour sacrifier un pion pour
libérer le fouet à faire rentrer tout
l'été son jeu vaut mieux avoir un fou
qui attaquent le roi qu'un fou qui sert
qu'un des cas défendre un point des
quatre qui est passive elle lasse il
coûte d4 d5 est donc cavalier seul
il permet et la food & 4 cloud le cavaly
seulement voilà donc là attention les
blancs menace pourquoi pas de prendre
ces six de prendre un g6 tout est
possible n'y a pas de problème le
cavalier ne menace pas de prendre un
homme il est cloué donc ça c'est
toujours intéressant dans l'es6 il
protège le cavalier en même temps ils
réitèrent l'attaqué
alors maintenant car il prendra
impossible puisque sur vous prenant à
mon reprendre et du cavalier et on a
gagné une pièce au passage le fou oui et
puis ça menace ton courage 4 ans et sa
menace tout reprend h4 avec la dame qui
protège la tour et donc perte de la dame
donc à ce qu'il y avait
voilà ce qu'ils avaient échappé à 40
cents ouais c'est ce qui l'a pas vu
alors on voit que c'est au 36e coup et
précision très importante pour le projet
chorus 2009
c'est que les organisateurs à la
surprise générale on décide de changer
la cadence de jeu c'est après depuis
maintenant en soit - 5 10 ans 1
dans l'es3 de haut niveau et même
partout en france les torts importants
on joue des tournois avec rajout
incrément l'orage ou du temps qu'un mot
assez moche mais ça veut dire ajoutant
effectivement à chaque fois qu'on joue
la pendule électronique nous rajoute 30
secondes 10 secondes dans les cas on a
toujours du temps même dans les cris de
temps pour pagerie n'importe quoi et là
les joueurs ne sont plus habitués à ce
rythme sans un crémant ce qui fait
qu'ils se retrouvent dans des crises de
temps dramatique où ils ont beaucoup de
coups à jouer en quelques secondes
alors certes c'est de leur faute c'est
une mauvaise gestion du temps mais c'est
quand même perturbant de jouer pendant
dix ans quand même cadence et
honnêtement et j'ai surtout c'est
l'ancien cadence si encore on avait
inventé un nouveau truc mais non c'est
pas si vivante choc
a perdu autant la première ronde bon ce
qui est vraiment regrettable parce qu'on
devrait faire des choses qui vont en
faveur du jeu - est clairement la tête
danse dit fisher parce que des fiches
qui est proposé depuis longtemps encore
une fois que rajouter le temps donc
c'est la même chose en faveur du jeu de
rajouter le temps à chaque fois qu'on
joue un coup et bien non on est revenu
en arrière et maintenant on voit des
joueurs comme un grand talent comme ils
vont tout perdre des partis autant dans
des positions gagnantes
voilà ce qui va complètement à
l'encontre du jeu et là sans doute c'est
un peu aussi ce qui se passe et pourquoi
car c'est navrant de voir ça pour le
goût du sang pour voir des gaffes pour
voir des pièces données en un couple
ouais c'est pas terrible faire des
belles parties cette accession alors fou
prend même les partis d'ailleurs bénisse
ou rapides sont plus agréables avec ne
serait ce qu'une seconde ou deux
secondes 3 secondaire à jour et chaque
coup ouais c'est très peu mais ça suffit
souvent pour finir les parties que c'est
vrai que les fautes met un peu de piment
mais pas dans un tournoi comme chorus
1/3 de beats oui mais pas encore eut il
ya déjà suffisamment d'occasions de
faire des fautes en vrai nous on veut
que les meilleurs du monde joue les
meilleurs c'est sûr vous prendre 5 donc
il faut le faire maintenant est trop de
menaces 1 trop de menaces comme les
programmes tous reproches cas d'un
proche cas pourquoi pas aussi ça fait
trop donc il faut prendre le fou le
cavaly ce qui est passé mon bon puisque
le fou était sans doute supérieur aux
cavaliers
on n'a pas le choix submergé par ses les
noirs ont bien réussi à renverser la
tendance
dame prend 2,5 et la menace de tout
reproche 4b un peu rance cette menace
d'un projet si ça me fait un peu un peu
inutile et surtout après d'un président
il n'y a aucune menace parce que la dame
protéger cette la tour à vis de protéger
là j'ai vite cette tour sur la colonnade
protège à 6 le roi en fait bizarrement
et très bien protégé de loin par ces
pièces europe et protégé de prépa mieux
protégés n'ont pas mieux que le roi noir
alors dépensé 6 il prend le pion c6 et
après des processions évidemment il a
cassé un tout petit peu cette structure
mais là déjà on est dans ce final de
pièces lourdes et après cette passe
tactique effectivement eh bien on va
s'apercevoir que
or on est rendus dans une finale enfin
une finale une partie est que des pièces
l'aude égalité matérielle
voilà des rois protéger de manière égale
des pièces qui vont être
également at il alors les finales de
pièces clos sont très souvent nul même
quand on est un tueur - donc là ce
niveau là on va voir une phase technique
un peu plus difficile voilà on va passer
dessus assez vite parce que il y aura
pas il n'y aura pas de grandes de
grandes
maintenant de grands exploits possibles
surtout que personne proposée pour
positions et d'annoncer faire un tour
sont encore un peu plus active après le
g5 par exemple je sais pas si c'est la
pègre avant d'aller au bout de la partie
parce que c'est des voies légales qui
sont son terme un projet 5 et quelques
coups on va on va juste les défilés on
va les défilés regardez vous allez voir
comment les grands maîtres font nulle en
finale de pièces l'ovale protection du
sidaction ces six prises angers 5 pour
prendre avec échec
en fait ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est
que les finales roy tour epyon contre
roy et tous ont très souvent nul dans la
mesure où le roi des rats faire mais bon
ça va refermer ce niveau là il n'y a pas
de problèmes qui sont même complètement
détendu au moment de perdre un pion au
final deux tours pour peu qu'ils aient
vu qui est nulle force et bien sûr voilà
un qui n'a forcé à notre disposition en
sacrifiant change de pions plus les puis
on s'échange plus on se rapproche de la
nulle en plus on va récupérer puis 1,4
ici il a il faut pas que le roi
s'échappe du puits au f 2 attention
attention risque de maths de l'escalier
de part et d'autre maintenant mais enfin
pourquoi pas très attentif quand même
bien sûr se prendre voilà donc encore
quelques coups vas y on ne peut pas
progresser en fait c'est un problème il
faut pas échanger les tours c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre faut garder au
moins huit ours encore plus sur wii
relativement quand on regarde deux tours
même quand son tour sa voix alors
effectivement si on échangeait les tours
la finale de plus en plus pas donc
encore quelques coups voilà d'avoir ça
va terminer un senior en fait les blancs
peuvent pas progresser voilà y'a les
change is it effet échanges ici et en
fait on ne peut pas gagner avec un pion
à des propositions de nul devant
l'arcadia kiné car c'est nous qui ne
pirate pas qu'un grain pirates en garde
clairement intéressante de partie quand
même c'est la façon dont car ça
d'abonnés son attaque
alors j'ai remarqué un endroit chorus
que carson est extrêmement bien préparé
dans ses ouvertures et qui joue t
vraiment tendu des variantes
d'ordinateurs sa loi c'est des variantes
qui sont préparés à la maison qui se
joue sur des détails et qu'au moment où
on obtient des bonnes positions les
bains ne parvient pas à les gagner
qui ne veut pas dire qu'il est mauvais
et évidemment ce qui veut dire qu'il
n'est pas très enfants de laon tour à
chorus et que ces préparations et bien
même si même si les a bien peaufiné pour
ce tournoi ne servent pas vraiment un
super état de forme il est attendu
maintenant il est attendu
oui puisque avant à bas par rapport à il
ya un an ou deux effectivement c'était
moins le cas rapport maintenant on voit
en lui le futur champion du monde est
plus un petit jeune prometteur c'est
clair donc on vous rappelle qu'en mai la
position clé ici c'était donc au 28e
coup là car c'est là sans doute manqué
il a joué cavalier prendre cavaliers des
5 il a sans doute manqué le coup gagnant
et qu'on vous a cité de thaler
rappelez-vous car les profs ou et suit
avec la menace ici d'un étranger 7 et
aussi sur dame prend donc cavalier fuite
ce coup super bien ici
cavalier 17 et la dame ne peut pas
quitter la protection du pion g7
parce que si elle part évidemment c'est
matt toujours donc voilà l'idée est le
seul coup on vous rappelle la
combinaison le seul coup khalef six ans
les cowboys qui pouvait permettre cette
de sortir encore indemne de cette
combinaison se heurte aux superbes d'un
grand tour tout simplement voilà voilà
et on a gagné une qualité une grosse
qualité belle partie en la fois
stratégiques techniques on voit aussi
comment on peut sauver une partie
c'est très important de voir ça donc les
finales de pittsburgh deux ans il faudra
aller travailler un peu pour mieux
comprendre on peut pas vraiment pouvoir
une fois
epinal ferlo sont souvent nul même quand
vous avez au moins il faut mettre le roi
devant le pion pas ses adversaires voilà
c'est exactement ça c'est vrai même
d'ailleurs contre roy et puis on
montrera toujours pareil car celle qui
aura attendu tortora chorus on va pas
tuer le suspense à fait d'actualité car
qui a fait 9 nuls en neuf rondes noires
ce qui montre qu'il n'est pas en format
pour autant il a été patient est attendu
il a gagné une partie enfin à la ronde
10 contre dominguez je crois donc il a
gagné une partie avec ce jeu cette
partie finalement il se classe 3e ou 2e
ex-aequo eux mêmes
il peut encore revenir on peut encore
revenir il a été patient peut-être que
là d'avoir une meilleure forme et je
pense qu'on va être ce tournoi avec deux
ou trois parties gagnées en plus des
nuls
donc voilà pour l'instant c'est devon à
rawdon qui met ce tournoi et vous pouvez
suivre les grandes surprises les grandes
scènes cardiaque in rajab offert au
niveau au dessus
suivre sur tournant sur internet vous
allez simplement sur le site officiel
chorus chess coach s.com voilà merci
jean baptiste pour cette analyse n'est
pas dû qu'au zoo on vous dit à bientôt
évidemment sur diagonale de tv merci de
vous être fidèle du dossier au revoir au
revoir